ah yes dude after
um
San Diego
the show uh on Saturday night we went to
this pizza place in Little Italy dude so
funny one of the dudes in rehab kept on
saying you're going to San Diego you got
to hit Little Italy like that's the
[ __ ] funniest thing I've ever heard
in my life you know
one time I heard a guy say oh you're
going to New York you know you got to
check out Central Park swear to God
swear to God he said it
and I was just like oh well yeah but I
don't know man
but anyway I went to Little Italy didn't
even know I was going a little Italy to
try saying that like that
uh and uh went there got some pizza and
it was by the way Mayhem it was mostly
like it was a crystallia book signing
and I felt very fortunate that everyone
in there [ __ ] wanted to get pictures
and say stuff to me but I couldn't
believe it dude you want to know who
kristalia fans are they're people who go
to pizza places to get slices at [ __ ]
12 30 A.M that's a crystallia fan so
when I show up and I want a [ __ ]
mushroom pepperoni slice only because
they don't have straight pepperoni
because I guess that's what's popular
now I gotta get the mushroom shits in it
which is fine you know do it do I like
it
I'm gonna you know I'm gonna douse that
parmesan cheese on it anyway I'm gonna
douse that [ __ ] just sprinkle it like
it's [ __ ] like Tony Montana in that
[ __ ] on his desk when he's just
looking forward with the mountain of
coke on it that's me eating a slice of
[ __ ] pizza with the parmesan cheese
on it
I haven't get rid of put the [ __ ]
thing up there of course so you know
what I'm talking about but yeah dude
um
you're walking where's your Parmesan
cheese
you know I want parmesan cheese because
I am addicted to parmesan cheese oh yeah
do yep I've got one more question you've
got
do you have pecorino Romano
no oh that's a big mistake you gotta
have pepperino Romano
that is actually something that Al
Pacino would be
a lot of people like parmesan cheese
don't they you know when I was in Italy
I was roaming around the streets and I
noticed the cheese was a little bit of a
different color I asked a guy
what is that he told me pecorino Romano
when I tried it and oh boy
I hate that pecorino Romano
um so yeah so I went in and got pizza
and got three slices like I'm
like I'm gonna only eat that
but I felt a little bit of embarrassment
getting a little bit more you know
because everyone else was getting two
pieces and it's like that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I was with nine people and they all
got two slices and some of them got one
and I'm like
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] coming from a guy
whose motto is a burger is a snack
right
and I'm no and I would get two pieces
but I'm no [ __ ]
right
it says like
I got three pieces because I'm no [ __ ]
and then sat down and one of the other
dudes there that was with us that was at
the show that was friends with my
friends there does construction and he
looked at me and he's like we gonna do
another one and I'm like yeah and
because the same time we said cause
we're no [ __ ]
so he said well I'll go get it what
should I get a whole pie and I said eup
and he got it and I ate three more
pieces
[Music]
pepperoni with pesto on it and it was so
damn good because I don't stop parmesan
cheese on it oh yeah
and then went back to the hotel
and then woke up the next morning and
then
when I'm sitting on the toilet dude
and I know it's gross but dude we don't
shy away from the truth here at this
podcast
we know it's gross but we don't shy away
from it
at this podcast just because it's gross
because it's real okay
so yeah just a lot of and
um and it's all good
um but you know
uh we have a good time and we ate the
pizza and then I woke up and then I
didn't eat till five because I was so
full off that pizza I get a [ __ ] I'm
I'm talking about I feel hungover when I
eat pizza now of course I've never been
hungover but I ate pizza and then I did
a little bit of a Greek salad at 5 00
p.m and then I ate some salmon dude you
guys don't give a [ __ ] about this but
honestly it's my life and I'm telling
you about it
um
get that new life ribs merch
crystalia.com we got them fall colors
and rock it out dude
and Rocket the frick out
[Music]